welcome to this video playing L
marmalade that's a Elma magram off Oh
time GM from Azerbaijan the former
training partner of garry kasparov they
played a ton of games and because part
of the youth ok that's a funky line that
is going for him would Indian mix just
plain normal stuff not really trying to
refute his setup which you can try to
refute it but not sure I managed anyway
so I'm playing normal moves and see
where it is leading ok so night in 144
93 or night eh so I let 491 looks a lot
like some kind of old Ben only check
been on your counter position only that
blacks bishop there's some somewhat
irregularly placed
okay stranger aim form play on the dark
square so can I have f4 should should go
for that Bishop g5 I can take d 6 that's
very important I have I need to have
this play on the g6 pawn if he just gets
dark squared Bishop Street it then this
is no good okay so he goes for what
exactly
95 maybe
mmm ciao okay do I go b3 i drede just
take it I can't take it Knight takes FTX
but should be three Bishop g5 okay did
you like it too much not sure yet how to
play this really the night in the d one
night maybe over to f5 something like
that that could be nice b5 could hit a
wall that i did not expect i can take
3-5 now 3 5 193 read still okay
then interesting line interesting mmm
Bishop g5 93's move Queen D 3 ft 5 I
cannot go if five unfortunately
I still like I just like that somehow I
don't don't really buy that wow I
thought you would okay thought you would
take on d3 here thought this should be
good for what in many ways this was one
of them offering the exchange I don't
think you should take it but maybe can
maybe take it but this would give me for
a d6 possibilities and so on yeah he's
not taking so let's see now I'm not
playing this putting pressure on the sea
por maybe night a form night a for
checking the sea porn and possibly
reroute into d3 where i'm looking at i'm
looking at five that was one idea yeah
maybe he can at some stage so take the
rook let's put this in the on the side
it's preparing what g6 maybe
if he takes it um he doesn't like him
yeah yeah okay but how do i play now
that's all funny with that with that I
can never really cheeky five that's 11
real problem there now I think he has oh
it is not really what is he doing there
he can never really take that when he
can take the rook but it's never a
problem let's say for me but the thing
is if he doesn't take how am I ever
getting anywhere Knight to f3 maybe all
this I can also check with the jeep on
that was cause of the light squares ok
now I'm going back
Jim that's the draw of course Gras our
third game plan yeah jim was interesting
with them with the exchange sack party
he simply never took it and he didn't
need to check them maybe I had some
other idea I mean the problem is a
little bit that my bishop on g2 is very
very bad and if he gets in something
like rook fa to f4 I'm busted yeah I
have to do something rather quickly the
comp is going for this idea makes quite
some sense I want to check though this
this exchange second a little bit I add
d6 as a computer suggestion that's
interesting 495 hmm say castles
now maybe no no no no possibly it's
better for what compass giving me quite
a bit of an advantage yeah I was keeping
before maybe yes yeah I'm playing this a
bit too big to um yeah I don't know I
didn't have any idea i am rook f3 even
calm just wants to go back and play this
pollution without dropping the exchange
yeah i think it's it's difficult to do
something I wanted him to tea but he
never he never he never ever takes and
at some point he plays this yeah the
computer is giving why the huge
advantage but I think it doesn't
understand that this is a fortress this
is a complete fortress even if I keep
Queens on I mean wait I'm just thinking
wait I can't can i maybe not I cannot I
was thinking if i get the knight to f3
but she always has queen f form so let's
say this this we are just it's just
shuffle like this this this this can
also do that go in here and it's just
that's a fortress the computer is on 0.8
but it's simply a complete fortress my
bishop is just a non piece on d1 so he
is keeping keeping all of it got it okay
well thanks for watching